how about the note that the characters
not relatable you know the idea that a
character is not related relatable or I
didn't care about the characters that's
probably the number one note that we
hear thrown around Hollywood and I would
say that that's also the number one note
that new writers are given when they're
working with material and we there there
are a lot of different things that can
contribute to this idea that a character
isn't likable or relatable and that's
why we have books like save the cat
we're in the title that's addressing
that very thing but at the same time
there what we like to do is we like to
go back to what Aristotle teaches about
what a character is and we feel like
that's so many people right now are
ignoring classic storytelling and
ignoring the basics of character and if
they only would look at what has been
taught over the you know thousands of
years about character they could
probably address this this question yeah
it's really not rocket science for all
of the the fact that it is the thing
that scuttles most scripts Aristotle
wrote 2,500 years ago in the poetics
that if you want the audience to have an
eventual cathartic experience in your
story that you need to have that
character be good be appropriate be
consistent and be universal right so
what does that mean right that that the
main character the protagonist needs to
be oriented towards a good quest that
the audience needs to sign on and say
yeah that's worth going for there so you
know look at the Odyssey this famous
Greek you know what does he want he
wants to get home he wants to be with
his wife the that's a good quest and the
audience goes yeah so one way to scuttle
your character right away suppose their
quest is I want to make a million
dollars I want to be the richest
stockbroker on Wall Street the audience
goes wrong right so we don't care now I
you know or you give them some kind of a
goal that that that just is like weird
or dark or hateful and
now the audience goes yeah I I don't I
don't sign on to that and so now they
disconnect right you know they need to
be appropriate that is the main
character in a story needs to have a
substitutional role for the audience
themselves they need to be somebody that
we feel safe with to say that's going to
be me in the story I'm going to travel
through that person's experience in the
story as though it was mine that's why
we laugh and cry and feel scared and
what's happening on a flat screen
because we've actually moved into that
character's life if it's working so if
you make the character so off-putting
Lee weird that the audience goes yeah
I'm not that guy you know think about it
the audience's people are sheep if
somebody comes in and looks goofy and
kind of strange nobody's like you know
everyone's like give that guy some room
all right so this is tricky thing in a
movie because you need your character
beauty quirky and better than the real
they need to be intriguing and
interesting and a little bit smarter or
you know good at something the audience
isn't but they can't be off-putting Lee
weird to the audience feels we nervous
about them now you can absolutely have
characters in the movie who are that but
not the protagonist the main one through
whom we travel who's going to stand in
for us has to be somebody that we feel
safe with right appropriate yeah and an
anti heroes are really popular right now
and we generally recommend for beginner
riders to avoid the anti-hero genre
typically because it's there they just
require so much skill to create a
character who is an antihero who is also
relatable who is also likable and you
know of course Walter White from
Breaking Bad is perhaps the best example
ever of an antihero who works but it's
because he has a very high stakes
relatable background as a as a he starts
out as a real human being more or less
and then he turns into a monster yeah
and that that leads to the third thing
aircel talks about consistency that we
can know why somebody is doing what
they're doing so their motivations
become huge that we understand their
motivations so the way to disconnect
your care
actor from your audience that make them
not care is if you never really clarify
what do they want what do they want what
are they trying to to do what they what
are they why are they doing what they're
doing if I don't ever understand why a
character makes a choice on the screen
then yeah I disengage so that
consistency becomes huge to make me
relate you know and then the last one
what what aerosol calls true that this
person struggling with a universal human
struggle that could be mine too so one
of the problems in a lot of movies is
the struggle is so externalized to the
particular world you know it's like wow
this is about a nuclear scientist who's
trying to blow up an asteroid and it's
like well why do I care about that I
will never do that so what has to happen
is it has BS he needs to blow up the
asteroid because it's the way for him to
show his son that he isn't a failure and
by oh now it's my story right but but
see the writer who doesn't make that
unfindable story that's common to all
people now I never care and and we see
this again you know the blockbuster era
of Hollywood it's so much about big
things happening in weird contrived
places and yet if they don't ever make
that connection to how is this a story
that everyone and every time in every
place could sign on to
you